Mikaelson Phoenix hey Michael welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show
hey are you doing better than I deserve
how can I help my question is uh where's
the mood of my in-laws that my wife's
going back to school and we're working
on paying our debt off become in debt
free good and now we're upside down in
our vehicle and we we walked away with
$70,000 from our house and I'm just
wondering should we take some of that
money and pay the car off or didn't
there sell the car and pay the
difference how far are you upside down
it's worth maybe 20 and we owe 30 on it
okay where'd you get them maybe 20 hey
Josh you're doing a little bit of market
research see and we have a little more
miles on ours than the other do so it
could be a little less yeah so what I
would do is jump on Kelly Blue Book calm
and look at a private sale appraisal on
there it takes you about 10 minutes and
that'll give you a more accurate than a
than a wet finger in the air on what the
car is actually worth
what's your household income right now
she makes 45 and I'm making 35,000 but
she's actually going part-time to start
nursing school okay so a $20,000 car
even if it were paid for probably
doesn't really fit in your all's life
with your income right now right correct
you wouldn't buy that much car with this
situation you're just in this much car
and so and you have $70,000 cash in your
hand how much other debt do you have we
have about three thousand dollars in
credit cards okay so you've got enough
to pay the car and get rid of the car
and get you about a five thousand or a
ten thousand dollar car that you pay
cash for right yeah so that'll use up
about fifteen of your money so we're
going to use up about 20 of your seventy
to do all that how are you paying for
school right now we're paying it out of
pocket good what is right now I mean you
don't you're not planning to do that all
the way through if we can we'd like to
theory has we actually have she has 20
$25,000 student loan debt already so we
really don't want to add to it from this
school or from the last one
no it's from a previous degree she got
how much other debt do you guys have
might have a student loan that's about
twenty eight hundred and that's all we
have okay go ahead and pay yours off but
she can delay hers while she's in school
and I'd pay off the car and pay off the
credit card and be debt-free everything
but her student loan while she's in
school and then I would raise my right
hand and I would use this money for her
to go to school if you have to I would
not borrow another dime okay the only
way to get out of debt stop borrowing
more does that make sense
Nate Parker camp yeah so we got a
quarter gonna clear up everything but
hers until she gets out and then we're
gonna use your income her income feed
the family and hopefully we can cash
flow and not mess with this house money
any more than we've already messed with
it just now right but I would rather use
that than I would go in debt okay make
sense make perfect then thank you sir